so despite what you may think even
though I really didn't like phantom
menace Attack of the Clones in my
opinion is the worst why because not
only was so little learned from the
mistakes of the first film okay there's
a lot less jargon but this one is just
straight-out
boring it is dull it's not very
interesting to look at it's not very
interesting to listen to the stilted
acting is still there the battle writing
is still there there's tons of things in
the plot that don't add up
which one matter if I gave a shit at all
what was going on and I don't even
Phantom Menace had the advantage that it
was picked accurately bad bad on such a
big level this one is just a boring me
Anakin Skywalker has grown up and
apparently has yet to develop a
personality as he apparently comes
across Amidala who is now not queen
another election I guess but
nevertheless he's assigned to protect
her after a few assassination attempts
the two eventually end up falling in
love but this is a big no-no as
apparently Jedi's can't fall in love
well that sucks not sure why that is but
whatever while their incredible
chemistry is being formed Senator
Palpatine makes a decision to form a
clone army these will eventually become
the stormtroopers that have different
voices in the later films that I think
they're talking about actually replacing
with Australian voices ah nevermind and
they're gonna take out more of that
political nonsense you couldn't follow
in the first movie except this time
Christopher Lee is in it
well that's cool I like Christopher Lee
but what's he doing there what's his
evil plan more political talk that you
can't follow and honestly that's about
it they tried to fill up all these other
things going on but it's not interesting
and since you can't really follow the
political talk sort of war talks or
anything like that
I don't really know what it ties in to
what's supposed to be important we get a
little bit of Anakin being separated
from his mother but he just kind of says
he's upset and angry and that's about it
there's not any more diving into it the
romance is kind of similar to they just
kind of say they're in love over and
over and find really corny ways of
saying it and that's it you never feel
any chemistry out of them because the
acting is so
stilted at this point I'm starting to
realize it wasn't the actors being
chosen that was the problem now don't
get me wrong some of them can actually
do okay
when McGregor is actually a pretty good
replacement for obi-wan Christopher Lee
is always a lot of fun and of course
Palpatine is always great actually just
realizing it's all the Brits the British
people are the only ones that give great
performances in these movies even in the
first Star Wars films Ford and Hamill
are a little whiny but with the
exception of James Earl Jones it's all
the British people that add the
credibility to the movie
maybe that's why Carrie Fisher tried to
do the British accent but regardless
what I'm getting to is that unless you
have a really really good actor it's
hard to make this dialogue sound natural
and you have to put a lot of trust in
your director that what you're doing
sounds and looks good and I think we've
established that Lucas has been out of
touch with being a good director for a
while so yeah I can't really blame the
actors for how terrible they're reading
these lines they're hard lines to read
and if someone is giving you the
direction to make it sound more and more
bland you're gonna just do it well the
only things people really remember out
of this film is the lightsaber fight
with Yoda people either seem to love or
hate this and yeah and somewhere in
between I understand both sides of the
argument on the one hand yeah it is kind
of neat to see Yoda with a lightsaber
it's cool to see him jump around and it
shows that such a little person can
still cause a lot of damage but like the
other half of people I kind of like the
fact that all you had to do was wave a
hand and a spaceship could fly by like
he was that powerful he had to do was
just point a finger he was bad in touch
with the force I don't know I'm just
glad it was something I didn't really
see before and it was kind of neat to
see there'll be a kind of goofy but
trust me that's nothing compared to the
other goofy scenes in this like a 50s
diner in a galaxy far far away yeah this
isn't like the cantina Mos Eisley where
it's like oh it kind of looks like a bar
but it's still kind of its own thing no
this is just a diner designed a little
differently did Star Wars have the 50s
come on there still has to be something
otherworldly about it not just Oh take a
diner waitress and make her a robot boom
and then the grand scheme of things my
brother brought up a really good point
he said what is the point of this film
and the
one after seeing Revenge of the Sith I
realized there really isn't any you
could just watch Revenge of the Sith and
you can figure out everything that
Anakin was in love that he was emotional
they wasn't ready to become a Jedi
everything you needed to know wasn't
that one these two films were completely
pointless no characters develop the
political talks are impossible to follow
and not very interesting there is no
real insight into anything and between
the two of them this one seems the most
pointless it's forgettable
it's dull it's not even that creative
you can't even really enjoy it for how
bad it is well ok some lines but it's
still mostly just a drag oh yeah that
line makes in the movie - from c-3po oh
it's so stupid anyway if you want to rip
it apart in it picket there's more than
enough material but in my opinion if he
came and say it's so bad it's good this
is the Star Wars movie you can easily
skip